my name is eamon weed
and i'm a sophomore currently studying
history in english
interestingly enough four years ago i
had the delight of meeting this
afternoon speaker
at the acton institute when i was a
sophomore in high school
and it was by mere coincidence that i
was asked to introduce him today
and so it is with great pleasure that i
introduce our next speaker
dr glenn arbory dr
glenn c arbory is the president of
wyoming catholic college
he earned his phd in literature and
politics from the university of dallas
he is taught at the university of saint
thomas thomas moore college of liberal
arts
the university of dallas and assumption
college
where he held the dalzon chair of
liberal education
he has served as director of the
teachers academy at the dallas institute
of humanities and culture and as an
editor at the people newspapers
in dallas where he won regional and
national awards for his writing
in addition to numerous essays and
reviews dr arbory is the author or
editor
of why literature matters the southern
critics
the tragic abyss and augustine's
confessions and its influence
please join me in welcoming dr arbory
amen reminded me last night when i saw
him that i had tried to recruit him to
wyoming catholic college
four years ago i'm glad now that we
didn't get him since
you know that's not a coincidence how
could that be a coincidence right
these things come around about 25 years
ago
jeff nelson at the intercollegiate
studies institute called me up one day
to ask me if i would write a book about
why literature matters
foolishly i agreed to do it and now
every few years i get an invitation from
someone who hopes i've by now
figured out what to say this time it was
my old friend doug jeffrey
when we were at the university of dallas
he drove
if not the only at least the coolest
carmen gia in dallas county
he persuaded me during the blank-eyed
laws of writing my dissertation
to read the novels of ross mcdonald
which i remember with particular
gratitude
i add to it my gratitude for this
invitation to hillsdale college
which has been a beacon of independence
in american thought
like the signal flare that homer
describes laid in the iliad
that goes pulsing high for men of the
neighboring
islands to see it in case they might
come over in
ships to help beat off the enemy
the question why literature matters
comes up now once again
in the context of liberal education
even before there were academies of
course poetry formed the minds
of those who heard it and literature has
been from the beginning of the western
tradition
a central way of educating the young
and enlightening their elders but at
least since plato
it has also been suspect because of its
power in forming opinion without the
authority
of careful argument so what is its
continuing
appeal it's not merely entertainment
though it unquestionably gives pleasure
even now literature is a common language
for those who are
educated and an ability to move
gracefully among literary references
to poems novels and plays
adds to beauty of character
why literature matters today however
becomes a particularly pressing question
when we think about the graceless
controversies that surround it when it
is treated primarily
as an ideological tool
back in december a piece about
hashtag disrupt text by megan
cox-guerden of the wall street journal
caused a stir when it exposed the
dismissal of the odyssey
by a high school in massachusetts very
proud to say we got the odyssey removed
from the curriculum this year
one teacher declared the teachers in
massachusetts apparently believed
that the longer ago the now banished
odyssey
was written the more objectionable it
was
they must have imagined an outbreak of
hurtful
cyclops jokes
perhaps the harsh judgment of the
marginalized lotus eaters
offended them in any case there's
nothing new
in their attempt to get the classics out
of the curriculum
the famous heihei ho ho western
culture's got to go
protest about the civilization course at
stanford occurred in 1987
and i remember a conference at lsu in
1991
when a cadre of college teachers would
not
read the aniod for the seminar
because it would be collusion in the
european
colonization of latin america
this is sensitive stuff so better not
read the odyssey either
according to disrupt text young people
should read only works written in the
present day
vernacular works that promise
excuse me that promote and center voices
that are lgbqtia plus
and bypoc black indigenous and people of
color
there are many reasonable answers
many reasons why it's important to keep
great literature
in the curriculum especially when it
requires
a challenging encounter with unfamiliar
language
reading a deeply engaging work older by
far
than the political structures and racial
divisions of the western world
one that precedes socrates plato and
aristotle by centuries
not to mention rome christian europe
and the americas might begin to overcome
what alan tate described as
provincialism in time
the belief that this moment of history
is the judge of all
others roger kimmel last night described
it as
presentism the sociologist peter berger
diagnosed the essential complaint
against the classics
50 years ago in a 1970 essay
called the obsolescence of the concept
of honor
he distinguishes societies based on
clear
roles for example the warrior world of
the iliad
from modern ones based on dignity
understood as
intrinsic humanity divested of all
socially imposed roles or
norms as berger explains
looking back from his perspective on the
1960s
quote the social location of honor in a
world
of relatively intact stable institutions
a world in which individuals can with
subjective
certainty attach their identities to the
institutional
roles that society assigns to them
this is what he understands by the
world of honor for example
in a world of honor a poet would find
writing an
ode or a sonnet part of the role of
being a poet
and he or she would find it an
opportunity
for demonstrating individual poetic
talent
in measuring mastery of
a challenging form against past writers
even romantic revolutionaries like
shelley
wrote sonnets in societies that reject
honor on the other hand institutions
this is burger cease to be the home of
the self
instead they become oppressive realities
that distort
and estrange the self roles no longer
actualize the self but serve as the veil
of maya
hiding the self not only from others but
from the individual's
own consciousness end quote
in other words the coercive demands of
the sonnet
distort or silence self-expression
and the poet should reject any social
role
that requires submission to such forms
so for contemporary movements like
disrupt text
the honored works of the western
tradition
have become institutional forms imposed
by those who control the canon
oppressive realities
from which students must be liberated in
order to find their own voices and
identities
murder strikes me as particularly
prescient when he writes that the
individual
who rejects the world of honor can only
hope to divine
to define himself quote in the
interstitial
spaces left vacant by the institutions
for example as self-expression in gender
identity
moves away from all socially imposed
roles
or norms it is lit its literature tries
to dissolve any standard of excellence
not based on dignity or individual
self-expression
ironically what this means in practice
is that writer is supposedly in the
church in the
cultural interstices win literary prizes
and prestigious university positions
that honor dissent as a new social norm
which makes it hard to describe these
writers is anything but the new
institutional mainstream one gets
confused
but let's avoid the sirens of grievance
two reasons that literature matters seem
to me most
pressing one is what my teacher at the
university of dallas
louise cowan called cosmopolis or world
making
in her introduction to the epic cosmos
in 1984
the second involves literature as the
mode of
concrete or embodied thought most
natural to the human mind
that is thinking in images comparisons
characters speeches and actions
the characters and actions of literature
are offered to the common judgment of
mankind
the best works endure because they most
wisely represent human and divine things
and give us the pleasure of recognizing
our lives
in more noble contours
let me start with the second literature
is a mode of thought
every household of parents and children
has a cast of distinct characters
whose various performances become
stories in the family
one of our four-year-old grandsons for
example
though a domestic terrorist by day
sang a beautiful solo of silent night on
christmas eve
much to our astonishment every classroom
could provide vin johnson with examples
of the humors
and so could every day in an office
anyone engaged in making an excuse me
and managing other people
thinks and characters and actions
who's brave enough to risk the boss's
rage over a personal
fault that's hurting the company what
will grove do to handle
this slight did you see how pritchett
treated that woman
how do you think klotko will react when
we present this proposal to her
this way of thinking is so natural to us
that we hardly consider it thought at
all
and attempts to reduce it to a system
say in the scenarios of business advice
books
always seem naive
the philosopher himself as dante calls
him
bases his account of virtue in the
nicomachean ethics
not on a set of principles but on the
character
and actions of the spudayas
the serious admirable man imitated by
those
who want to exhibit courage or prudence
novels plays and epics work
through the depiction of character at
the beginning of the iliad for example
only achilles will stand up to agamemnon
when he brings down a plague on the
entire army
and only achilles suffers the mortal
insult of the king
through his mother achilles asked zeus
for the honor that agamemnon has denied
him
even though it will mean the deaths of
many and the defeat of his own friends
both men bring harm to their own army in
other words
but which is more noble agamemnon or
achilles
for anyone who's read the iliad the
answer is obviously
achilles saying why takes the reader
into the depths of the poem
later in the elliot the acayans have
been driven back
inside their newly built wall and the
trojans occupy the whole plane diameters
volunteers to find out how the trojans
are arranged and what their plans might
be
who does he want with him on this
dangerous
night ray nester huge ajax
menelaus no he wants
odysseus and so would you
the judgment is instantaneous why
if you had to tease it out you'd say
that unexpected situations don't rattle
him
that he's quick-witted and physically
powerful
and that he's a superb liar
we naturally condense what a person says
and does
as well as what other people say about
him into a single
charged image of who he or she is
it can be wrong it often is wrong
and this possibility of error also forms
part of what literature shows
king lear vanishes the daughter who
loves him most
othello is so wrong about desdemona
thinking that she has shamed him in his
culture of military honor
that he cannot let her live but even as
he kills her
he adores her praises her tries to save
her from damnation
after he kills her he discovers her
innocence
and cries whip me ye devils
from the possession of this heavenly
sight
blow me about in winds roast me and
sulfur
wash me in steep down gulfs of liquid
fire
othello becomes for us a figure
embodying
many cultural complexities a part of our
thought
like him hundreds of other characters
from literature
become part of the way we think as
though we knew them personally
clydum nestra penelope
dida cordelia
hester pran literature helps form
judgment and right feeling in fact
it helps this order experience itself
the accuracy of its depictions may be
constantly tested against people we know
or might come to know as a teacher it
never
occurs to me to try to abstract a
concept
from characters like raskalnikov captain
ahab
or don quixote as though they were
merely
as though they merely stood for
something that could be more
tidily handled on the conceptual level
in 19th century saint petersburg
raskolnikov lives in amelia
a radical social thought and his mind
has been
formed by fashionable theories
but unlike many others he feels the
compulsion
to test himself by putting these
theories into action
there's a kind of integrity in that even
though it involves killing an old pawn
broker
but he therefore suffers the full
consequences of what he does
a student learns raskolnika
not a concept that he stands for and not
even really
the character raskolnikov as though he
were merely an exhibit of the novelist's
imagination
knowing raskelnika pulls the reader
into the whole rich social and spiritual
context of dostoevsky's novel
great characters like people we've known
deeply in our lives become complex
attractors that order and deepen
daily understanding literature leads us
into thinking more deeply in and through
our own experience
literature as a mode of knowledge also
involves a deep pleasure in language
itself
this would be a good time to put up the
poem
and the revelation of likenesses for
example
gerard manley hopkins and his sonnet the
starlight knight
thinks in a series of metaphors about
the stars
his language is dense with alliteration
full of heavy stresses that form a kind
of counterweight to the upward vision
all of this in the imperative mood
imagine a student used to reading works
in the present day vernacular
suddenly buttonholed by hopkins poland
look at the stars look look up at the
skies
oh look at all the fire folks sitting in
the air
the bright burrows the circle citadels
there
down in dim woods the diamond elves
the elves eyes the gray lawns
cold where gold where quick gold lies
wind beat white beam airy abiles
set on a flare flake doves sent floating
forth at a farmyard
scare all will it is all a purchase
all as a prize by then
bid then what prayer
patience alms vows
look look a may mess like on orchard
boughs
look march bloom like on mealed with
yellow sallows
these are indeed the barn within doors
housed the shocks
this peace bright paling shuts the
spouse
christ home christ and his mother
and all his hallows
now we could pause over the word quick
gold which
hopkins invented according to the oxford
english dictionary
quicksilver we know it's the older and
more descriptive term
for mercury and it's kind of jittery
liveness
so we make the transfer and see the gray
lawns cold where
gold where quick gold lies
the cold dew drops quick with the gold
and sunlight on the lawns
the stars become the features of this
kind of english estate
they flare like white beam leaves tossed
by the wind
they burst into sight like doves scared
up from a farmyard
and this estate is for sale
hopkins tells us by then bid then
by with what with prayer patience alms
vows
again he commands us to look
in the last metaphorical transformation
the whole sky of the starlight night
becomes a single structure
if you follow what he's doing in this
last part
these are indeed the barn that is the
whole
night sky you're looking at is to be
conceived
as this single barn
and inside the barn are the sheaves
stored up after the harvest the gathered
saints
let's say remember the old song bringing
in the sheaves
right but these are also notice the
enjambment notice the way that
the the shocks is left there at the
beginning of that next to the last line
the greatest shocks are those
of the unexpected surpassed hope or
understanding
the greatest shock of all is the last
image
of immense interior light
pouring out through the tiny gaps and
holes
in the palings of the house
of this barn that houses christ and his
mother
and all his hallows as of the whole
starry sky
were simply a vision of that light
breaking through in these tiny
places why this repeated demand to look
as though we had never seen the skies
the russian critic victor shlovsky
wrote a century ago that perception can
become so habitual
that it becomes algebraization
wordsworth complains little we see in
nature that is ours
but hopkins shocks us out of laying
waste our powers
look at the stars look look up at the
skies
he also shocks us from the way that we
see dew
or wind blown trees or the flowers on
spring orchard vows
thinking in metaphors we discover the
beauty of familiar things
put next to each other as hopkins says
in another sonnet
beauty keeps warm men's wits
to the things that are now this in
itself is already
an accomplishment in the late by the
late 19th century when hopkins is
writing
time and space and divine purpose it all
suffered major shocks from modern
science
the deep time of geology the increasing
vastness of the discoverable universe
the apparently random adaptation of
creatures to environments in darwin's
theories of evolution and in general
a de-centering of man in the human
intellect
and a disenchanting of the world inside
the
outside the cartesian subject so
what hopkins is doing here is a bid
toward that other dimension
of literature that i think we see in
what louise cowan calls
world making or cosmopolisis
this cosmos this world that the poet
makes
as louise cowan says establishes
the mundus imaginalis wherein reside
the universal qualities that make up the
human condition
it's the glory of the poetic cosmos to
show these verities in action
embedded in matter bearing the weight
and expressing the hope of the finite
order
end quote a poetic cosmos
is a whole apprehended by the
imagination
everywhere charged with meaning
a lived world of sky and earth the
living and the dead
cities and households gods and mortals
it's an interpretive order a felt world
that gives a place to the whole realm of
human experience
world making doesn't mean rhetorically
affirming
the structures and institutions that are
already there
so much as it means subjecting them to
poetic
revision and scrutiny
for example think what homer does in
both the iliad and the odyssey
agamemnon's outrageous insult to
achilles calls into question
the justice of awarding or denying
honors
when the standards of the one in charge
are personal or politically biased
suppose that someone's greatness exceeds
the city's capacity to contain it
in its system of social roles
and conventional honors does such
greatness
destroy the city or transfigure it
that's the question that the iliad poses
in the odyssey marriage undergoes a
major
reimagining the reunion of odysseus and
penelope
doesn't restore something normal i think
i think we tend to think that
that you know here was a marriage of
penelope and odysseus
medicines gets back home and
everything's back to normal
but the re reunion of odysseus and
penelope
is by no means restoring something
normal
their marriage is establishing a
startling
unheard of ideal of fidelity and mutual
mindedness whoever had a marriage like
this one
when jack maratin writes that poetry is
an inner communication
between the inner being of things and
the inner being of the human self
i think we have to take things to
include not only
natural ones but also institutions
um i could say more about this but i
want to move on to the idea of
of what a cosmos looks like by looking
at the ancient world and particularly
about looking
at at the um iliad and the odyssey
next to the the modern cosmos that i
think we
feel sort of adam braided in hopkins
poem
divine presence is everywhere in the
ancient world
in the iliad in the odyssey zeus the
cloud gatherer rules the sky
an unpredictable poseidon the sea
bleak hades governs the realm of the
shades
the underworld and far below him lie the
halls of tartarus
where the ancient defeated gods lie in
their eternal bondage
so what is the good disrupt text might
say
of offering young readers and outmoded
cosmos
over gods nobody believes in instead of
showing them their own social
circumstances
in the vernacular again there are too
many things to say
but perhaps the most important
is that entering an epic cosmos keeps
cultural identity and historical
circumstance from being a prison
if there's a barrier of disbelief it's
easily overcome
and this poetic cosmos is not closed to
us
because we inhabit it with the cues of
imagination
natural to us from our own reality
one scene from the iliad there's a line
in my book why literature matters
which ends well the whole point of it is
that god loves the iliad more than any
other poem
this is why i keep coming back to this
one scene from the hillary will help
make my point here
at the end of book eight the
consequences of achilles withdrawal
from the fighting have become
unmistakable
hector has just succeeded in driving the
terrified of kayans
back inside the wall that was hastily
constructed
to protect the ships and the shelters
for the first time in the war the
italians are on the defensive
and hector exults in his unprecedented
success
as the trojans stay out on the plane to
prevent the ikayans from escaping in
their ships
they expect to end the long war by the
next day
which agamemnon on the other side had
thought earlier in the poem
in this mood the citizens bring out from
this city
oxen and fat sheep and all speed
and also the kindly sweet wine with food
out of their
houses while the fighting men heap up
many piles of firewood for all the
grimness of war
this scene feels almost carnivalesque
the city is wide open and the soldiers
are enjoying this respite
from their years trapped inside the
walls
homer ends this book of the poem with
the complex
simile whoops
there we go so with hearts made high
these set night long by the outworks of
battle
and their watch fires blaze numerous
about them
as when in the sky the stars about the
moons shining
are seen in all their glory when the air
has fallen to stillness
and all the high places of the hills are
clear
and the shoulders out jutting and the
deep ravines
is endless bright air spills from the
heavens
and all the stars are seen to make glad
the heart of the
shepherd such in their numbers blazed
the watchfire as the trojans were
burning
between the waters of xanthos and the
ships
before illian a thousand fires were
burning in the plain
and beside each one set fifty men
in the glare of the blazing fire light
and standing each beside his chariot
champion white barley and oats the
horse's
waited for the dawn to mount to her high
place
i love this simulate
so what's going on in it
one thing that's going on in it is
that there's a movement of the
imagination away from the scene of the
fires
far away right to the shepherd in the
hills looking up at the stars
i'm reminded when i read this of
our students at wyoming catholic who go
out on a winter trip in fact they just
went out last week
and they go up into the tetons and at
night they do cross-country skiing
and you know build uh their
ice houses and see these stars
with this unpolluted sky that this
shepherd three thousand years ago
in in homer simile would have seen
then you come back down to the fires
which have been immortalized
in this in this kind of vision of the
heavens
and then you come back to each fire with
the light and warmth of that fire
and then almost like a flash of a camera
for a second the faces of those 50 men
around each fire
and then the last movement of the image
to those horses
leaning over you know almost as though
the white barley
were a kind of meal of stars
leaning down to the earth gaston
bachelor
writes that a particular cosmos forms
around a particular
image as soon as the poet gives the
image the destiny of grandeur
the grandeur of homer's image pulls us
directly into the cosmos of the poem
and its unfolding drama these trojans
would not be spending the night outside
the city
had zeus not nodded his head
to achilles mother thetas at the end of
book one
and promised to give achilles honor by
the end of book eight
the absence of achilles from the
fighting has
drawn these trojans out onto the plane
full of a false confidence under hector
they enjoy this night with hearts made
high
only because they do not imagine the
return
of the warrior achilles
the sense of vastness the starry sky
the nearby ocean the walled city
all these give space to the unfolding
destiny of achilles
the hero deprived that his conception of
supreme immortality
and now being given his poetic
compensation
embedded in this moment of trojan
celebration
are already the fires of the destruction
of troy
these households bringing out their food
and sweet wine
will very soon be ransacked in the
passions of war
but for a moment homer transcends the
dramatic circumstance of war
in a scene of clarity and beauty
and although such moments in retrospect
reveal more deeply
and poignantly the unfolding tragedy
they also remain in the imagination
as a promise of a more enduring peace
and a truer homeland
the peculiarity of the imagination is
nobility
wallace stevens wrote during world war
ii
and this inherent nobility is the
natural source of another
which our extremely headstrong
generation regards its faults and
decadent
i mean stephen says that nobility which
is our spiritual height
and depth depth end quote
there's nothing more conspicuously
absent from the literature of our own
day
than the world making grandeur of the
imagination
we feel the urgency of getting past
hypersensitive intersectional grievances
and trigger warnings but how do we begin
the ennobling
recovery as the h says of the soul
and sailing to byzantium it needs to
study
monuments of its own magnificence
these world making works that give us
the great characters and actions the
enduring metaphors
but precisely those are being rejected
so suppose we take our cue from achilles
instead of letting our great literature
be insulted
and canceled we deliberately withdraw it
we deny homer and shakespeare say
to those below a certain income level
or those who identify themselves as
belonging to certain social groups
and we greatly encourage letting them
read
only things that flatter their own
current level of knowledge
and implicitly we forbid them to aspire
to anything else
this is outrageous but i am hard pressed
to say
what the difference is between this
program and disrupt text
a pleasure to meet someone denied the
classics in college
who comes upon them later in life and
can hardly believe
the extent of the earlier deprivation
at places like hillsdale and wyoming
catholic college
we study the great tradition of
literature in which
wisdom adds to wisdom
the bible the odyssey the aeneid
the divine comedy paradise lost
the great plays of shakespeare and
others the great novels the great lyrics
we hold on to the past because we hold
on to hope
ends his essay the noble writer and the
sound of words
with a simile both of consolation and
challenge
as a wave is a force and not
the water of which it is composed which
is never
the same so nobility is a force
and the manifestations of which it is
composed
which are never and not the
manifestations of which it is composed
which are never the same nobility of
spirit
exists now as it has always existed
and more than ever we need a deeper
knowledge
of our great literature why to help us
cultivate
and honor in our students the
imagination to renew
our institutions and make a new world
from the best of the old thank you
[Applause]
thank you dr arbory we now have time for
some q
a if you have a question please make
your way down to the front
hi thank you for the talk i was
wondering do you think that the
prevalence of superhero characters in
like modern
storytelling is a result of the
deprivation of like epic heroes
i i think this that's a great question
in fact when i was thinking about
the the absence of grandeur and
literature
i'm really thinking more about sort of
mainstream novels and plays and so on
well in the popular imagination i guess
we can call it
you know there's a teeming kind of world
of superheroes and
semi-gods and so on that's going on
and these have have huge popularity
so um even when even when you're trying
to get across the
the nature of the homeric gods you know
the tempt
temptation is always to say all right
okay what's the difference between say
captain america
and you know uh iron man or something
you know what what's the difference
between the kind of
mutation that leads to some kind of
superpowers
and mere technological advantage
but i think the impulse is there toward
some kind of
heightening some kind of middle
way of imagining between um
ordinary people and and the sort of
inaccessible divine
so yeah i think you're onto something
there thank you
thank you for your talk um as someone
who
and i'm sure there are other people in
the room like this planning on teaching
in the future anything from elementary
school all the way up to high school and
possibly beyond
i wanted to ask um for a piece
either a piece of advice or how you
yourself have inhabited
these these aspects of world making and
concrete and embodied thought in your
own teaching and in your own classes
thank you um i think the most important
thing
to do when you're teaching literature
and i have to say i learned this most of
all from louise cowan
is to make the students or to help the
student
imagine what's going on in the story in
other words
if if you're always going at a poem
or a novel in order to
extract from it what seems to you the
salient idea
you're not treating it as literature
you're treating it as a
as a kind of candy wrapper you know and
down inside is the real thing
there's there are always depths to
anything that's important
in literature but the first thing to do
is to
make that effort of imagination which
takes you deeply into the story
i remember louise cowan teaching moby
dick when i was a
graduate assistant and she was
treating a novel which i had read before
but didn't like
and suddenly reading into those scenes
of the novel
when ishmael and queequeg and starbuck
are chasing this huge pot of whales
and suddenly they get drawn into the
center this kind of still
center where all the whales are circling
around
and they can see down into the depths of
the sea
at the you know young leviathans and
their mothers
i mean it's just marvelous you know as
soon as you get the image
instead of simply concentrating on what
seemed to you the conceptual parts
i think this is true of children as it
is of college student
that is this is this is the first thing
you do
um imagine into the
into the nature of the world that's been
given in that in that work
what's it like to inhabit
a body in that world i think that's
important to to always think about
in other words when you're reading
something you enter it
in a body you have a kind of fictive
body or imaginable body
and to the extent that the writer is
good you find yourself grounded and at
home
in that world so that's i think that's a
first way to go right with that thank
you great question
thank you so much for coming to talk to
us so being classically educated we have
the opportunity to read these books
and to be helped through them but
sometimes
because of that some of my favorite
books are classics but how do you
do it when you're no longer in school
and you're no longer being taught
these classics are you doomed is it once
you're out of college and are no longer
being taught the classics you can't
enjoy them
how do you enjoy these classic books
well you don't you just go watch the
avengers
you know no
i think having people who also like to
read them is pretty important
so communities of readers
i think are vital to anything that
you're really going to be able to
continue to do
it's great to read these things on your
own
it's just as you say more difficult
i think it's easier to read novels
than it is to read say the epic poems
but
still i think you always long for the
conversation that goes on about these
things
just as you talk about um bosses
and colleagues and friends right you
want to talk about
the the characters and actions that you
read about in this in this literature
because
of the way it illuminates you know the
things around you and gives you a
different perspective
on what might have gotten stale um if
you start seeing
your um your friend is clydum nestra
you're
you're worried you know if
if you if you start seeing um
penelope uh in in one in your mother
you know your mother is striking you as
penelope tell your dad to go home
all right you know it's been 20 years
go home dad you know i'm sorry
thank you
thank you for coming today um and uh
so obviously when we read these like
traditional
books um and like the epics especially
um we're learning from there from the
experiences
of like of timeless experiences really
and as you said wisdom building on
wisdom
um and in kind of more modern literature
like
you were talking about it's somewhat
blind to that
like wisdom which so it's
so it's hard to build upon that when
there isn't when it isn't there in the
first place
so how important is it for
for us to maybe expose ourselves to the
more modern literature when they might
make the argument as well
that only reading traditional books
flatters our own ideas like we are just
like like it like we can say sometimes
about the other side
yeah excellent question um i think
we should read everything you know i
read
modern novels just as i read the you
know the classics
in fact you know you you're looking all
the time i think for the work
that's going to be a breakthrough
something that's that's going to
really address us in a way that is
world making in the sense i'm speaking
of
we need writers who who aren't just
trying to undercut everything that's
good about the tradition
but really try to to remake it you know
to see how to take it into
a different uh social circumstance
political circumstance um what do you do
in a
um in a world where not everybody
believes in god in the same way right
that dante's world
did how do you establish that relation
between the human and the divine
that's so crucial to understanding what
it feels like to be in the homeric world
right where are we finding that
done so i think reading modern
literature is
always a kind of urging of modern
writers to take up this challenge
and to really try to see what that would
be like if you
reintroduce the divine say into
into novels
i like the way you put that yeah why
aren't we just saying that
we're flattering ourselves by reading
these same things
you part of my point and this is
something i
wish i could have gotten into a little
bit more in the paper
is that great literature is always
taking those institutions that we want
to hold up as
is permanent and unchanging and
you know melting them down rebuilding
them
seeing how they how they um can sustain
the kind of challenge that say dante
gives to the church by putting popes in
hell
right you know you're putting you know
and then having the the pope currently
in hell say oh i thought you were the
next one i was kind of waiting for him
you know dante is scathing
in his criticism of the church but he's
doing it in order to
try to restore the institution same
thing with politics
right same thing with with marriages
we need to constantly be thinking how to
renew
the the inner being of these
institutions just
as we try to renew the world around us
with metaphor and
such things thank you for that question
thank you for your talk um so i was
wondering what you were what you thought
of
uh film adaptations of these great
classical works like
those of shakespeare or homer i mean
obviously they you know
something is lost going from page to
screen and they often take some
liberties
but on the other hand it it's it's a way
of exposing a more casual audience who
wouldn't read those books naturally to
those great stories
so do you think there's a value in that
absolutely
um in fact i think
you know i'll probably draw criticism
for this but i think we're in a
in a great age of a certain form of
um depiction you know it's more or less
like the serialized novel
um some of the series
you know like the wire or breaking bad
you know you raise your eyebrows but
these are you know these are
these are pretty major accomplishments
and i think when you can
serialize great books
in a way that doesn't diminish again the
the the character of the world that's
being depicted in those
i think it's a great service um it might
it might tell us that we're
uh back in an oral culture i don't know
you know
but it's it's not that shakespeare's
works
are written to be
handed out um you know to to readers
they're presented as as works in the
theater
and you know and there's a lot of
speculation about why shakespeare
himself never even bothered to edit them
you know for publication so that kind of
you know presentation film you know all
these things
i think is is part of what gets these
works across
thank you
thank you so much for coming to speak to
us today um a lot of modern education
will require reading
some of these more challenging books
like the scarlet letter and the odyssey
and everything like that
but a lot of students will end up just
spark noticing it or not even bothering
to read it at all
or and a lot of authors are just coming
up with interesting plots that don't ask
the big questions
so how do you how would you say we
change the attitude
from trying to find the instant
gratification and the entertaining part
of these stories
to asking the bigger questions and
changing our perspectives
good question um it's kind of the
question right now isn't it
um i think you
i'm suggesting at the end of my talk
well you just forbid them to read them
that'll do it you know you may not read
the scarlet letter
you will never understand it it's too
risque you know you know whatever um
there there's a
there's a way that i think the real loss
we face and i think this is
you know in large part because of the
way that we spend our time
on virtual media on you know cell phones
and
internet is just simply the loss of the
power of concentration
so how to encourage that um
in wyoming catholic we forbid cell
phones
you may not have a cell phone while
you're a student at wyoming catholic
college
in other words you know you don't get to
have it when you go back to your dorm
room
you know you don't have one so one
i mean that's that's almost like a
gesture but it's a gesture in the
direction
of concentration of the capacity to
take some time and to sink into
something
in a way that allows you to experience
the language of it
and those deeper questions that
naturally arise from it
it's also good to have people around you
in your classes who care deeply about
these things
and and push you right so that it's not
something that you can easily skate over
yeah
the spark notes world of literature
yeah that's that's that's the great
enemy
thank you
thank you dr harpery um i was just
curious
it seems like the modern preoccupation
with literature
is and the reason that they dismiss the
classics
is that it everyone is preoccupied with
feelings and so the modern authors you
know they try to
get us to try and feel something and
try not so much to think about something
how would you try to make the argument
to the modern
thought that you know where a
well-formed person
should cry at the
should cry at the end of
the divine comedy with the image of the
divine where
that should be something that you should
have
feelings toward um there's a
there's a chapter in my book while
literature matters called the
intelligence of feeling
and the premise of it is that
well-formed
feelings contain a great deal of
experience
and a great deal of thought it's gone
into
what what people have done uh
in what you've read and what you've
experienced in your own life
i look to feeling as
you know pretty strong key to the truth
of things
if it's well formed so
i don't want to dismiss feeling
on the other hand this
appeal to sentiment i thought what roger
kimmel said last night about sentiment
was dead on
that this is there's a kind of um
sentimentality
in in a fake emotion
and a lot of what we see now that
uh isn't earned it isn't part of
what would naturally unfold from the
actions and circumstances
of work you appeal to you know a certain
kind of
uh cultural trope or meme and that
and that's um that is supposed to be
sufficient
you know it's a cue cry here right um
whereas the truly deep works
like king lear when cordelia comes out
and lear's arm it's at the end of that
play
you know if if you're not feeling
anything there
you know there's there's something
deeply wrong
so great question thank you
we now have time for one more question
thank you for speaking i have a question
about
you mentioned that literature helps form
and
give us the help helps form us and helps
give us the proper dispositions that we
should have towards life
and that classical literature is is uh
useful or takes a large part in
forming us in that way do you think that
modern
or some modern literature can be a
d4 deformation or the antithetical
to that process and then should we avoid
reading
things that do participate in a
deformation process and then how do we
avoid
uh those malevolent
works again an important question
i i think it's hard to know in advance
what a work is going to do to you i'm
i worry about this i worry about
students who
who have moral qualms say about me
reading madame bovary
you know they're scared they're going to
be tempted and someone
well you know you're going to be tempted
toward much worse literature if you
don't read it
you know i think that it's difficult
to judge what's deforming
if you haven't been formed
right and if you have been formed i
don't think
that the danger of deformation is going
to be very powerful
so i mean we know certain things are
deforming pornography is deforming
right but an honest attempt
to give
a kind of vision of the world we live in
through literature
doesn't seem to me deforming unless
we are conscious from the outset that is
keith says
it has a design on you you know that
it's
it's trying to get you to do something
or to think a certain way
if it's a an honest attempt to depict
the the world that we live in
and the characters who live in it um
i think you have to risk a little bit
you know
good question though thank you and thank
you all i appreciate it